everywhere you look there are empty body
bags
ice being Swept Away
and the air filled with the stench of
death
this vast room is where the bodies of
the Dead were brought family members
came here to identify
their loved ones and were able to take
those bodies home but many remain
unidentified they've been taken to morgs
it is here that you get a sense of the
sheer scale of the tragedy
96 people were taken home
but 193 more were taken to mortuaries
volunteers became their preservers and
protectors
it has been very difficult
lots of dead bodies coming in lots of
relatives coming in for searching and
for their dead and difficult for them to
identify from the very bad shape bodies
are in bad shape so it's very difficult
[Music]
husband was killed she tells me she
can't believe she's lost him that she's
full of worry and her children are
constantly crying out for their father
she also had to identify his body
I felt totally senseless she says
[Music]
at the site of the crash you can see
where lives were ripped apart
carriages of chaos panic and pain
in the debris here you can see bag bits
of torn clothing shoes phones destroyed
just look at the scale of this mangled
wreckage it's impossible to think anyone
survived and now their lives laid bare
[Applause]
[Music]
work is now underway to restore the
tracks investigators suspect an
interlocking track management system
malfunctioned it's meant to direct a
train to an empty track when two meet an
alert oncoming trains where to go
Commissioner of rail safety the
commissioner of rail safety which is an
independent body their inquiry is about
to be completed they will give us their
inquiry reports Whoever has done this
this huge criminal act will be
identified soon
trains are at the heart of India's
travel after building many new ones the
government will now have to focus on
restoring faith and what it already has
Cordelia Lynch Sky News odisha India